[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم حلقه جديده مع
الاعلام والصحف الاسرائيليه وصديقنا
الدكتور احمد فؤاد انور ليخبرنا بما يجري
داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي مساء الخير معال
الدكتور مساء النور سيد بي صديقي المحترم
انت ارسلت لي يعني عناوين كثيره
شغلت الاعلام الاسرائيلي فاستاذنتها
نوجزها بقدر الامكان عشان نغطي اكبر عدد
ممكن من الاخبار هل استاذنك يكون البدايه
الاول هل بيتعلق بخرق الهدنه كنا نامل ان
الهدنه تطول يعني املا في توصل لاتفاق
نهائي او تسويه من وجهه نظر الاسرائيليين
لماذا تم خرق الهدنه او انتهاء الهدنه
يعني بعد لحضرتك والمتابعين كلهم الحقيقه
طبعا الجانب الاسرائيلي يروج طبعا منذ
اللحظه الاولى ان جت الساعه س واللي هو
الديدلاين لتجديد
الاغاثه اللي هو الهدنه الانسانيه لليوم
الثامن ولم يتم تسليم القائمه المطلوبه من
الجانب الاسرائيلي اللي هي فيها 22 سيده
22 سيده فلسطينيه اسرائيليه هاخد انا 22
من غزه اطلع 66 طلع اضرب في لاه اه فزي ما
يطلع بقى 66 ا فده جزء الجزء الاني ان هم
قالوا الساعه 7 و10 ان في صاروخ اتضرب من
غزه ف الامور ابتدت يبقى في ضرب متبادل من
ناحيتين انما هم بيتهم حماس بانها خرقت
الهدنه ده الروايه الاسرائيليه انا برد
على الحكايه دي بقول اولا المطلب
تعجيزي ليه تعجيزي لان حماس
في الدفعه السابعه طلعت مانيه يا سيدات ما
طلعتش ال 10ش الاتفاق ان هنوصل ل 10 ايام
كل يوم مقابله 10 واحنا اتفقنا ان الفئه
دي اطفال ونساء بتضرب في لاثه من عندك
تطلعوا قصادهم برض اطفال ونساء ف الجانب
في الحمساوي قال انا ما عنديش 10 ما كملوش
انا عندي يه سيدات واطفال اسرائيليين اه
خلاص اخر ثمانيه هو ما فيش اطفال فهو
الجانب الاسرائيلي يرى بان في معلومات
توفرت من المحتجزين اللي طالعين اللي تم
تحريرهم تم افراج عنهم من جانب حماس يمكن
الاستفاده منها ده تفسيرك ده تفسيري
والحاجه الثانيه ان في صور تم التقاطها
لعمليه التسليم والتسلم مع الصليب الاحمر
فيمكن تحليلها فقوم بمغامره والافراج عن
المحتجزين او عدد منهم بشكل ليه انا حللت
كده لان في فئه ثانيه جاهزه
ومش صعبه اللي هي فئه الرجال غير
العسكريين احنا خلاص خلصنا الفئه الاطفال
انت بتقول ان في نساء انا بقول لك انا لسه
بدور ما عنديش ففي فئه جاهزه اللي هي رجال
مدنيين والاسهل منهم ما حوالي 20 الاسهل
منهم مهم اللي حوالي 20 السيدات ولا
الرجال الرجال اللي المتبقين مدنيين يمكن
من الداخل تقسيمهم الى مدنيين فوق سن
التجنيد عنده
جاهزين وفوق سن ال 50 عاد تجاوز ال 50 وال
70 فده عيب على فصال المقاومه وبياخد دوا
وهكذا فعايز يخرجه والجانب الاسرائيلي
المفروض لا يعني يابه بارواح الاسرائيليين
ويحاول المفروض يهتم ا هو حاليا اثبت ان
هو لا يابى بدليل ان هو انطلق في الهجمه
بكل قوه وان هو بيقول يا جماعه انا مكمل
في الشمال ومكمل في الجنوب اذا من وجهه
نظرك انه بخرق الهدنه عن عمد اي هي
اسرائيل
والحجه التي سوقتها اننا على مدار السبعه
ايام السابقه كنا نتفاوض على تسليم نساء
فلسطينيات في اطفال مقابل نساء واطفال
اسرائيليين بمعادل واحد الى ثلاثه صح لما
جينا عند اليوم الثامن والمفروض كان
التاسع اسرائيل طلبت من حماس عر نساء في
اليوم الثامن وعشر نساء في اليوم التاسع
على اساس ان الاطفال قد تم تسليمهم صحيح
اعترضت حماس وقالت ليس لدي عدد كافي من
السيدات ما فيش ومن لدي من السنتهم مجندات
يعني جنود لهم حساب اخر اذا اردتم استئناف
الهدنه اسلم مدنيين من الذكور رفضت
اسرائيل وبالتالي انهرت الهدنه وانت
بتستني ان السبب ان اسرائيل فعلت ذلك ان
هي اصبح لديها معلومات من الاسرى او من
المختطفين يمكن ان تستغلها في تحرير باقي
الاسرب القوه وفي تفسير اضافي اللي هو ان
ممكن تكون اسرائيل رات ان من غير مصلحتها
يستمر الامر على هذا النهج ايه هو النهج
ان في ابتهاج في الشارع الفلسطيني بخروج
الاسرى وان في تصريحات وصور ايجابيه من
الجانب الفلسطيني ساعه التسليم والتسلم في
ابتسامات وديه والامر ده كان مدع السخريه
يعني من اكثر من جهه الجديد يا استاذ سيد
ان هو بيقولوا
ليه لغايه دلوقتي المحتجزين الذين تم
الافراج عنهم الاطفال خلاص لهم خصوصيه وما
يعرفوش ليه النساء ماتكلمتش ليه ما طلعوش
في الاعلام اتكلموا هم شاركوا في مظاهرات
انما ما طلعوش فاخر تخريجه ان حماس
اخافتهم وطلبت منهم ما يتكلمو لما يرجعوا
اخافتهم بينما تفسيرك انت اللي قلته لنا
المره اللي فاتت انه هم اسرائيل بقت ترفض
تنظيم مؤتمرات صحفيه اه هي اسرائيل بتقول
خلاص بعد المؤتمر الاول اللي تحدثت فيه
سيده مسنه بشكل ايجابي لم يتم عمل اي
مؤتمرات صحفيه ورفض ان هم يصرحوا للاعلام
بس في مجتمع مفتوح زي كده ده هارتس عندهم
صحيفه هارتس لوحدها عامله قلق في مجتمع
مفتوح زي كده تستطيع السلطات منع الناس من
الحديث اه ما هو نتنياهو بيضغط لاقاله
رئيس الرقابه الرقابه العسكريه في اسرائيل
بتقول انا نتنياهو بيهددنا وان عايز يمنح
حاجات خاصه بيه وبزوجته مالهاش علاقه
بالحرب فهو في ابتزاز من ناحيتين في تضييق
على الاعلام نتنياهو بيقول انا استفيد منه
لمصلحه صورتي انا والرقيب بيقول لا انتم
سايبين الحاجات اللي في المعركه وداخلين
على حاجات هامشيه في خبر ا يعني متداول مش
عارف مدى دقته في اللغه العبريه عن تصور
او تفاصيل جديده لخطه التهجير تحت اسم
جديد وعدد من الصحف تحدثت عنها فهل يمكن
ان انت تقول لنا ما هي التصور او الثياب
الجديده للخطه القديمه اللي هي تهجير اهل
غزه انت عارف حضرتك ايه وكاننا والماء من
حولنا قوم من حولهم ماء ف المشكله في
الايه في التسميه كان التهجير القصري هو
اللي سيء مش العمليه اللي على الارض هي
اللي سيئه فقالوا خلاص احنا مش هنسميها
تهجير قصري هنسميها تهجير طوعي بس 2 مليون
يخرجوا برده
[ضحك]
في واحداني قال لا احنا هنعمل تقليل لعدد
السكان اهنا ماعملش تهجير تهجير قصر ولا
حاجه ف الخطه ايه الخطه التملص من الرفض
المصري التملص وتجاوز الرفض الامريكي
امريكا اعلنت لا وال الرفض العربي كله مش
الرفض المصري بس اصل المشكله ان امريكا
دخلت وقالت تحت اي ظرف من الظروف لا نقبل
بالتهجير القصري من غزه ومن الضفه ام
فخلاص احنا مش هنسميه تاجير قصر فهو كده
قال يعني هو كده التف على الرفض الامريكي
اي صحيفه عرضت او اشارت الى هذه الخطه
اللي هي بتسميها خطه ريه صحيفه ايه
هايوم دي في الاساس مجانيه طلعت لضرب
الاعلام المستقل مجامله لنتنياهو في
اسرائيل هيوم من المؤيدين لنتنياهو
حتى ثلاثه اشهر مضت عملت انقلاب على
نتنياهو ملك غير سياسته في امور حصلت جوه
الجريده ما بقتش داعمه لنتنياهو بقى العكس
بتتصدق طاء زي بقيه الصحف المستقل طيب
ماذا كتبت اسرائيل يوم يعني اسرائيل اليوم
عن هذه الخطه اسرائيل يوم بالنطق العبري
يعني اللي هو بتتكلم عن
ا كونجرس عضو كونجرس عضو كونجرس قال ان
انا بتقدم بمشروع قانون ل تهجير 2 مليون
من غزه اه وربط ذلك بالمساعدات للدول التي
ستقبل وحددها بالاسم مصر وقال تاخذ مليون
تركيا تاخذ نص مليون واليمن ربع مليون
والعراق ربع مليون هو
يعني هو برض كان المشكله في الكوته يعني
مش في يعني هو متقدم بمقترح انا مش عارف
هو كانه يعني يقوللك احنا نتصرف في مليون
معرفات خد انت مليون يا مص مليون وانتصر
بمعرفتي في المليون الاني ويوزع الباقي
على اليمن والعراق وتركيه ام فهو الخطوره
بس انه بيقول ان اخدت موافقات من الحزبين
الرئيسيين في امريكا اه اللي هو
الديمقراطي والجمهوري
وان ان الامور تسير يعني هو اسمه جوي
ويلسون عشان اللي احب يعني انا بحاول اض
اه جوي ويلسون هو اللي بزعم الحكايه دي
وهو اللي سرب لاسرائيل ها يوم للتمهيد
امام الراي العام بان الامور يعني في افق
لليوم التالي بعد انتهاء الحرب اللي هو
فكره ان الحل يكمن في في التهجير القصري
الطوعي يعني القص الطوع القصر المسمى
بالطو هو الفكره ان انا دلوقتي دمرت
القطاع فالناس هتعيش ازاي ما فيش مستشفيات
ما فيش كهرباء ما فيش ميه ما فيش سكن يعني
اللي بيتمتع
ببلاستيك السيد عنده رفاهيه حظه حلو
البلاستيك اللي انا عندي خيمه مش قماش
بلاستيك فبقى انا مميز ان انا اتوفى واتلف
ببلاستيك برض حظي حلو لان في ناس بنسف
وبتت الاشى اه فالفكر ان انت بتضغط بشكل
غير مسبوق وللاسف التصريحات يقولوا قللوا
عدد القتل المدنيين يعني مش حرام يعني
اقتله اقتله بس مش كتير شويش بالعقل انا
بس في في ما يتعلق بالخطه ديت القصه يعني
ا يعني فيها عده امور يعني واحده من
الامور اولا انا طبعا ماعرفش ليه اختار
مصر انا فاهم انه هي المرشح الاول
لاستقبال اكثر عدد في التصور الاسرائيلي
ايوه انه يختار اليمن يختار العراق يختار
تركيا دي حاجات عليها علاه استفهام ام
يعني ليه الدول الثلاثه دول انا تقدير
الشخصي قد اكون مخطئ يعني ان في
ا يعني جرين لايت من تركيا اه هناخد ناخد
كام ناخد عدد من الفلسطينيين من اه ناخد
كام وقصاد ايه دي محل تفاوض اه فدي
بالنسبه لهم دي خلاص نص مليون كده ايه ان
شاء الله ايه خلصنا منه اليمن عشان ضعيفه
وعشان منقسمه وعشان فيها ثلاث قوى يعني
بتتن حر في الداخل هم اكيد مش هيطه في
شمال اليمن بقى يديهم في الجنوب مثلا يعني
انا مش متخيل اصلا ان هي اكاديميا تمشي
واقعد اخلي دي طب خليها 200 هنا و300 هنا
يعني هي نظريا تمشي انما عمليا مش هتمشي
والله انا يا معالي الدكتور معها بالاموال
مهما كان اغراء اصل الرفض هيجي من الجانب
الفلسطيني هيجي منج الجانب العراقي هيجي
من الجانب الشعبي واحنا جربنا الحكايه دي
قبل كده ان احنا نطلع على لبنان اضطرينا
نخش بيروت وندمر بيروت وتطلع مقاومه اكبر
حتى وانا معايا رئيس جمهوريه مساند وعمل
معايا
اتفاقيه سلام حتى انا عندي ك سنه كام
لبنان سنه كام جميل 82 82 انا دخلت لغايه
العاصمه اول عاصمه عربيه تسقط بجيش
الاحتلال اطريت انا اصلا طلعتهم لبنان
اللاجئين طلعت الفلسطينيين من اراضي ال 48
ورمتهم برا الحدود وخلصت طب ما انا جربت
الحل ده اضطريت ان انا اروح بقوتي واخش
اريل شارون يخش على بيروت ويحاصرها وبرده
القوات تطلع بسلاحها تقصد انكون
الفح ده لم يحمل اسرائ حزب الله طلع اقوى
من منظمه
التحرير انا انا عندي يعني مشكلتين في
قبول هذه الروايه يطلع عضو كونجرس يطلع رس
الامريكي وزير اسرائيلي هو الوحيد اللي
جوه مجلس الوزراء المصغر ومجلس وزراء
الحرب هو الوحيد اللي
نتنياهو قال له المعلومه دي وهو الوحيد
اللي كلفه بدعم هذه الفكره يعني ده مين
اللي كتب برض اسرائيل هيوم اسرائيل هيوم
نف الصحيح ده خلاف حواره او التصريحات عضو
الكونجر تلقى في الفكره هو نتانياهو شخصيا
وهو خايف على الفكره لانها حساسه حسب وصف
الصحيفه فما قالش الا الوزير ده الوزير ده
ا ميد ان يو اس
ايه وزير هواء امريكي يعني ومولد امريكا
وحصل على الدرجات العلميه بتاعته من
امريكا ولسه رايح اسرائيل 98 اه فهو
امريكي يعرف يقنع امريكا يعرف يتفاوض مع
امريكا يعرف يداعب المشاعر الامريكيه ازاي
على اساس ان اسرائيل عندهم صعوبه في ده
يعني مثلا هو نتنياهو ميدن يو اس برض اه
مفه يعني درس هناك و ووالده كان يعني مؤرخ
هو يقدم على انه مؤرخ هو خطوره ابوه ان هو
سكرتير جابوتنسكي جابوتنسكي هو اللي
البريطانيا بتقول عليه ارهابي اه
جابوتنسكي هو مؤسس الليكود الحقيقي
واليمين متشد والراجل اللي هو اسس لفكره
ضروره استخدام العنف المفرط لفرض سموها
الصونيه التنقي حيه اه هنرجع لكبت مسك لكن
احنا انت بتقول كده انه
نتنياهو وفقا لمستشاره اسمه ايه مستشاره
اه اسمه رون دليما ده تلقى بيقول ان انا
انه
نتنياهو تلقى الفكره هو المستشار بيقول
الكلام ده كده علنا ان نتنياهو تلقى
الفكره اه ان هو كلفني ده مش السري يعني
هو بيقول اه يعني المطار السري زي المطار
السري كده هو بيهي الراي العام ان في افق
ان احنا نتخلص من الناس دي اصل في ناس
تقوللك يعني انا دلوقتي مصر رفضت هنعمل
ايه امريكا رفضت هنعمل ايه يعني هو مش
مشكله كا بيت انا هديته ولا كم واحد قتلته
انا بعد كده هحل سياسيا ازاي انا مشكلتي
مع السكان مش مع حماس والله هي المشكله
فييها حاجات كتير بس انا من ناحيه اولا
انا مش متاكد رغم انه في مستشار لنتنياهو
بيقول ورغم ان في عضو كونجرس بيقول ده
مساله تدعوني للاهتمام بس هي برض في حاجات
تدعوني للاندهاش يعني يعني ايه اللي
بيخليهم يعني انت بتتكلم بتلقائيه بتقول
ان تركيه توافق هل تركيا توافق على تفريغ
القضيه ما دي ده اتهام خطير يعني ما هي
بيسوقها ازاي اردوغان اصله يا محن كده
بيقول انا هاخد اطفال غزه اطفال غزه هاخد
كميه من اطفال غزه لان الضرب ده يعني لا
يط اه ما هو قال انا بتكلم على الاعمار
انا مش عارف احنا فين والاعمار فين قال
انا هشارك في الاعمار وهاخد اطفال من غزه
الاف وطبعا الاف يعني هاخ خدهم بعائلاتهم
مشخد طعا طبعا فهن خش ف هو ما عنده هو
يقول لك دول جدودهم مثلا كانوا اتراك دي
مسؤوليه اخلاقيه تفسيرك لان علشان بس ل هو
قال هاخد الاف من الاطفال الفلسطين تمام
ما هو برض في ع حتى لو افترضنا ولو ان ده
مساله محتاجه تدقيق طب ما هو في العراق
هيوافقوا ليه وفي اليمن هيوافقوا ليه ا
على كل الاحوال هذا هو الكلام اللي اطرح
انا اير بس لوزير الدفاع القائد العام
وزير الدفاع الفريق الاول محمد زكي قال
قال التصفيه والمغامره غير المحسوبه من
جانب اسرائيل بوضوح وعالم يعني لا يحترم
الا الاقوياء فانا قصدي ان هم بيحاولوا
اعاده تسويق الفكره حاولوا الحاح عليها او
المراوغه باعاده تسميتها باسماء اخرى
واحنا بناخد مواقف اقوى لان في خطوره
حقيقيه هيفضل عندي سؤال لكن يعني هيبقى
طرح يعني انه في النهايه لما اسرائيل سوف
تمضي قدما في في عمليه الضرب العنيف جدا
من الشمال ثم في الوسط في خانيونس ثم في
الجنوب مصر قد تجد نفسها قدام سيناريو
خطير جدا اما ان هي ترفض هذا المخطط
وبالتالي تترك كل هؤلاء الملايين او
المئات الالاف على حدودها لا حول لهم ولا
قوه يا اما ان تسمح لهم يا اما ان تشتبك
مع اسرائيل يعني استمرار المخطط بالشكل
اللي هم بيقولوا عليه ده مفتوح على كل
الابواب يعني واحد احنا يعني لن نصل الى
هذه اللحظه سن طبق انا التقدير الشخصي
يعني الفلسطيني بيقول احنا هنروح فين
هنروح في البحر احنا قالوا لنا امشوا من
الشمال دلوقتي هم نازلين على الجنوب انا
بقول لحضرتك ان مصر واللي هيحصل على الارض
هيكون مختلف عن اللي حصل في
الشمال ليه لان هو في الشمال بيقول انا
دخلت وعملت تمهيد بالنيران و 31 اكتوبر
دخلت بري ولغايه اللحظه دي في حوالي
700000 فلسطيني في شمال غازه ولغايه
دلوقتي انا بقول الانجاز بتاعي ان انا
بحصر جباليه من بره في ده ده يعني انت
تعمل ازاي هتعمل ايه في خان يونس هتعمل
ايه امام مقاومه حقيقيه تعمل ايه وسط
الكثافه السكانيه غير العاديه انت بتقول
ان المهمه ان هو بيقولوا كده لكن ده كلام
في الهواء يعني اه ان هو مصر هتضغط بشده
لان لسه قدامنا اوراء ضغط لم نستخدمها زي
زي سحب السفير
السفير بتاعنا المتوجه الى تله لما يتوجه
السفير القديم الاولاني و بيكمل المهمه
خارج الفتره الزمنيه بتاعته فدي رساله ان
احنا في رساله ثانيه ان انا هسحب السفير
انا مش هقدر اطرد السفير الاسرائيلي لان
هو سحبوه هو وطاقم العمل من اللحظه الاولى
وبالتالي ما عنديش سفير اطرده اصلا اه
فالحل ان انا اجيب السفير بتاعي زي ما
عملنا في 82 لما دخلوا بيروت وقعد سنوات
هنا عندي تحركات زي الاشارات دي التصريحات
وزير الدفاع دي تفهم في اسرائيل بان لا
الخط الاحمر موجود بجد مش خط احمر يعني
بعد اسبوع ممكن نخش في جدول اعمال هم طبعا
بيقولوا ان مصر مسؤوله عن الانفاق انفاق
احنا الانفاق دي اكتوي هنا بيه ودمرنا
عشان مكافحه الارهاب فالار حاب عندنا قل
بقول مصر مسؤوله لان دول اصولهم مصريه
اللي هم ناس اهل رفحه يعني غزه كلها المصر
غزه كلها اصول
مصريه طب معالي دكتور في خبر كده يعني لقى
اهتماما كبيرا وهو انه
ا اثنين مستثمرين اثنين اساتذه يعني في
جامعات امريكيه ولهم خلفيه استثماريه في
اسواق المال
ابتدوا يضعوا علامات استفهام على حركه غير
طبيعيه في البورصه الاسرائيليه وتحديدا في
2 اكتوبر صح ايه الحكايه اثنين اساتذه في
جامعه كولومبيا وجامعه
نيويورك عملوا بحث عن حركه التداول في
الاسهم القياديه قبل 7 اكتوبر وقالوا احنا
تواصلنا لحاجه غريبه جدا ان يوم اثنين
بالمقارنه ب 20 سنه فاتت في ضعف
عمليه الشورت حضرك بشرح لنا بقى الشرت
عشان ما
البطش هو القصه ببساطه طبعا كل اللي
مهتمين بالبورص عارفينها ولكن اللي مش
عارف يعني البورصات معظم بورصات العالم
بتسمح ما يسمى بالشورت سلينج يعني ان واحد
يبيع ما لا يملكه
ا الاول يبيع ليه وازاي ما لا يملكه وده
علاقته ايه المساله بسيطه خالص ان يجي
مستثمر في الحاله ديت في البورصه
الاسرائيليه
ويبيع في البورصه وفقا للقانون اللي بيسمح
بكده سي مثلا سهم ب 100 ويبيعه دلوقتي
حالا ل انا يا سيد ابيعه لاحمد ب 100 انا
بعمل شورت سيلينج ليه لان انا متوقع ان
السهم ده هينزل هيبقى ب 50 فانا هبيعه
لاحمد ب 100 احمد هيقبل ال 100 وبعدين
وفقا لتصوره انا لو صار السهم ده هينهار
هيبقى ب 50 فانا انزل السوق واشتريه ب 50
واديه لاحمد وفقا للميعاد المطلوب احمد
هيشتريه مني ب 100 يبقى وانا اشتريته ب 50
من السوق يبقى انا استفدت 50 اه فاذا كان
في حركه شرط سلنج كبيره في يوم 2 اكتوبر
اذا من اقبل على الشورط سلنج هم مستثمرون
كانوا يدركون ان هناك حدثا سوف يؤدي الى
انهيار اسهم فارادوا الاستفاد من الانهيار
المنتظر ايوه فيدعو تحنو تلقفت بقى
التقرير دوت وابرزت وقالت لا احنا نشوف
ولازم نحقق هل حماس هي اللي سربت الخبر هل
حماس هي اللي استفادت بالملايين دي هو
الفكره بس ان الجميع كان يعلم ما عدا
اسرائيل يبدو كده لان هم بيقولوا ان في
تحذيرات جت لنتانياهو من الداخل والخارج
هو بيقول ما حصلش ان الصحفيين كانوا
عارفين وقعدوا يصوروا بهاي ريشن وكانوا
الجوم في 7 اكتوبر اه يوم سبعه كانوا
يعلمون فكمان بيقول ان المستثمرين كانوا
يعلمون فاشتروا اسهم قياديه مبكرا لان هم
عارفين انها ايه
هتنهار وهو مش يعني كلام عاوز حذر لانه
كلام خطير ان كل المستثمرين
يعلموا يعني الحاجات اللي انت قلتها ليها
تفسير يعني الصحفيين يمكن انه المقاومه
اخبرتهم ان في حدث تعالوا سجلوه فممكن
بعضهم راح بعضهم ما راحش ممكن انه في
تقارير استخباراتيه بتحذر ممكن دائما
بيكون في
ارهاصات انما انه كمان الارهاصات دي تبقى
وصلت للمستثمرين
ومتوقع فدي مساله عاوزه تتخد بحذر يعني
لانه ا هو مش وارد يعني ان المستثمرين او
المجتمع الاسرائيلي كان يتوقع ان هناك
حدثا سلبيا بعيدا عن 7 اكتوبر انه عمليه
انفجار نتيجه الضغط الاسرائيلي في الضفه
في غزه في شمال لبنان انا كنت سامع اصلا
من
بعض يعني زعامات المقاومه ان هم كانوا
بيتوقع هجوما اسرائيليا على غزه في كل
الاحوال بعد انتهاء الاعياد لا هو بعد
انتهاء الحرب على الضفه الحرب ما بتنتهيش
على الضفه هو الفكره الاساسيه ان زي ما
حضرتك بتقول كده اي مستثمر عاوز جبان راس
الملك بتاع فد جبان بيبقى عنده كده توقع
ايه اللي هي حصل بيقول لا الحكومه دي جت
من ديسمبر اللي فات لسه ما قفلتش سنه اهي
ماشيه غلط ده في ناس بيتكلم ان في حرب
اهليه ان هو بيغير شكل اسرائيل ففي خلاف
بين الجناحين معسكر نعم لنتنياهو معسكر لا
لنتنياهو قد يشتبك وفي ناس قالوا مش هنروح
للاحتياط فده السيناريو ان انا كمستثمر
اقول لا الازمه دي ممكن تتفق التصعيد
الضغط على الضفه ومحو حواره والتصريحات
ديت ممكن تؤدي بلده حواره في الضفه وسموت
شو اللي قدله بالتصريح ده والانتهاكات من
وزراء مش من المعارضه خاصه ان بعضهم بيدي
صلوات تلمود داخل المكان وده مجرم وفق
القانون الاسرائيلي نفسه ف الفكره ان
الاجواء نفسها قبل الاشتعال المستثمر يقول
والله يعني المسار ده هيحصل فيه انفجار
عادي كويس بس ده يقول لنا ان بصفه عامه من
ديسمبر ومع تصاعدها في فبراير ومارس ان
المستثمر ي ا تقابل نتنياهو كل ده يعني
مستمر من اسابيع وربما شهور لكن ككل ان
تتركز عمليه البيع المكشوف وفقا للتقرير
وهو بعشرات الصفحات ا يوم اين اكتوبر اده
ثبت اذا ثبت لانه انت بتقول ان الجهات
الاسرائيلي بتحقق بتحقق طبعا هيكون في
علامات استفهام محتاجه تبدد يعني اه لا
يعني بقول لحضرتك في الضفه احداث تقول ان
هيحصل انفجار لان اللي بيحصل في غزه في 60
يوم ما هو بيحصل في الدفع طول السنه بمعنى
ان في 160 بيت بيتهد في السنه اه في في
الضفه اه فكل طول السنه عمال اهد في بيوت
انت معكش ترخيص انت بنيت بدون ترخيص انت
عليت انت ساكن ما عندك مخرب مش مش بيهد
شقه ولا بتاع بيهد الاار
فبالتالي الاستهداف المقاومه او حتى
المشتبه
فيهم الاعدام الميداني انا قريت خبر قبل
ما اجيلك خبر لم اتوثقت منه انه طائرات
بريطانيه بتقوم بعمليات استطلاع فوق
القطاع هل اي صدى لهذه العمليات او اي
معلومات لا مش محتاجه هي القطاع صغير جدا
وفي منطاد ممكن يغطيه من الجانب
الاسرائيلي الكلام عن قطع بحريه كتير في
البحر المتوسط الكلام على تنسيق بشان باب
المندب انما هو ده بيبقى طمانه للراي
العام الاسرائيلي ان احنا معانا قوات
ثانيه وان احنا في ناس هتساعد وان العمليه
متغطيه تمام لان مافيش مصداقيه قوي
للاستخبارات الاسرائيليه دلوقتي دلوقتي في
اي حاجه تانيه لافت نظرك قبل اختم على
الدكتور لا هو طبعا بيقولوا ان في 80 دوله
ممنوع خالص ان انت تزورها انا مش مستغرب
هو طبعا 80 دوله ممنوع على تمسح الدوله
رعايها الا يزورها اه و اناا مش مستغرب
لان هو قالوا ممنوع تسافر خالص قبل كده
قالوا اللي عايز يسافر يا ريت ما يسافر
دلوقتي وعملوا على خريطه للعالم فيها
الولايات المتحده ممكن تزورها باللون
الاخضر مايكرونيزيا ممكن تزورها سيشل لو
مش سيشل جزر سليمان اه في اسيا كلها في
دوله ولا اثنين وفي جزء اخضر كده في
افريقيا مش عارف تبع لدوله ايه انما
افريقيا كلها حمرا طبعا مصر حمرا خالص
الجزائر وهكذا فهو الفكره ان انا الروايه
بتاعتي مش ماشيه ان الناس مش مصدقاني ان
انا عشان اروح ايسلندا العب رياضه الاقي
الاستخبارات الداخليه لازم تروح معايا
تحرسني فانا الى متى يعني تتجاوز باب
المندب والف رجاء الصالح
عشان المسار الطويل علشان اتجنب الحوثيين
اللي امتى نفسيا انا هفضل مستمر افضل مخبي
على شعبي انا ما بقولش الصور بتاعه غزه هو
في الاسرائيل العادي بيقول للجيش الاس ما
تقصفه اكتر من كده في ايه القصف ده عشان
مش شايف الصور طب هو ليه مش شايف الصور ما
كل وكالات لا هو بيتابع التلفزيون
الاسرائيلي بيتابع قناه 12 هي اكتر واحده
معارضه او مشاغبه او بتقول راي مختلف ده
راي نعمه شومسكي على كل حال انه حتى في
الشعوب الديمقراطيه الاعلام بيبقى قادر
على انه يوصل رساله النخب الحاكمه وبيقدر
يخدعهم يعني وفي في جامعه دكتور احمد
بيشير الى فكره انه عدد الدول اللي
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بتحذر رعاياها من
زيارتها تزايد بشكل كبير ووصل ل 80 دوله
صحيح فده معناها انه بقى الاسرائيلي حركته
محدوده جدا في بمجرد الزياره فضل عن
الاستثمار والسياحه الى اخره بتقول ايه يا
مع دكتور كنت بقول ان حتى الولايات
المتحده بقوا يقولوا الجامعات تحت سيطره
المساندين للفلسطينيين جماعات عريقه في
الولايات المتحده لدرجه ان هم عاملين
كاريكاتير ان بينزلوا اليافطه وكاتبين
كليه يحيى السنوار كليه يحي
السنوار فتخيل هي دي الولايات المتحده
الخضراء يعني اللي ممكن يزورها هيلاقي برض
ناس متحفزه لان المشاهد ا صادمه يعني جزيل
الشكر مع دكتور تحيات سي تحيات شكرا جزيلا
لحضراتكم ونلقاكم في حلقات مقبله ان شاء
الله لمتابعه ما يقوله الاعلام الاسرائيلي